merci beaucoup d'être l'homme monsieur
Gignac ce soir merci merci de
l'invitation
monsieur Gignac pour un troisième mois
d'affilée mais on reste à 6,9% on est
encore loin d'être dans une situation
idéale pourquoi ça recule si lentement
en ce moment en fait il faut bien penser
que même si le prix de l'essence se fait
en sorte depuis trois mois ne décélérer
on le vu le Marie-Claude l'esprit au
niveau de l'alimentation on voit des
accélérations même le prix des meubles
au-delà de 10%, vous savez le dollar
canadien qui a quand même faibli
beaucoup au cours des derniers mois est
une bonne partie de l'explication et on
va se dire je pense que des fabricants
des commerçants qui utilisent les crèmes
que dollars pas mal pour passer des
hausses de prix parce que si on regarde
les marges bénéficiaires en fait madame
Saint-Arnaud c'est des Hauts de 40 ans
donc les profils entreprises seraient
très élevées et là on commence à se
poser de graves questions parce que
excluant énergie l'inflation
fondamentale sous-jacente il y a pas de
décélération depuis trois quatre mois
c'est le cas c'est le cas également au
Canada parce que vous l’évoquez
justement monsieur Gignac bon évidemment
aux communes on a on s'est prononcé en
faveur de la tenue d'une enquête sur les
pratiques des grandes chaînes
d'alimentation est-ce que les profits
des épiciers sont trop élevés est-ce
qu'on en a profité vous semblez croire
que oui ben écoutez est-ce que c'est les
commerçants ou c'est plutôt les
fournisseurs qui eux passent les
augmentations de prix et finalement au
niveau des épiceries on n'est pas on est
obligé de les mettre au consommateurs il
y a quelqu'un dans cette chaîne
d'approvisionnement là qui semble
pouvoir profiter un peu de la situation
parce que sinon c'est très difficile à
comprendre pourquoi que on continue à
voir cette poussée là on peut mettre du
double crème on peut le mettre sur la
baisse de l'or canadien mais je pense
qu'il faut chercher un peu ailleurs et
je crois que je trouve ça intéressant
que du côté d'Ottawa là provinces
qu'on commence à regarder sérieusement
parce que si on regarde les marches
bénéficiaires des entreprises on est
dans des Hauts de 40 ans bon si on met
de côté l'alimentation
en fait la question qui demeure c'est
pourquoi pourquoi est-ce que les hausses
de taux d'intérêt multiples la Banque du
Canada depuis le début de l'année on
n'en sent pas encore les effets la
demande reste très forte combien de
temps encore avant que ça freine la
demande c'est géniale
ce qui s'est passé au niveau des mises
enchantés plutôt cette semaine ça pas
loin de 300 000 unités au Canada et
pourtant ça devrait être le secteur qui
commencerait être frappé le premier là
au niveau des hausses de taux donc il y
a beaucoup d'argent dans le système les
gouvernements ont été généreux on se le
dit et aussi les banques centrales ont
tendait à monter des taux d'intérêt donc
à quelque part vous avez une demande qui
demeure très très forte une offre qui
continue à être contrainte et il y a des
délais de transmission de nos autos
d'intérêt donc dans ce sens-là si on
regarde les chiffres le Canada selon les
prévisions du fondateur international
c'est quand même le Canada au 5g7 qui
connaît qui va connaître en 2022 qui a
reconnu en 2022 la croissance la plus
forte au sein du G7 et l'an prochain
c'est parmi encore les plus forts même
si ça devrait ralentir beaucoup donc
clairement il y a beaucoup d'argent dans
ce système le bilan des ménages est un
effet de richesse avec l'immobilier qui
a augmenté et ça prend d'eau aux autos
comme vous l'avez mentionné sans doute
le faux s'attendre à toi encore de
points la semaine prochaine et
possiblement qu'on va se rendre à 4 et
demi ou 5 % parce que on a encore des
taux d'intérêt en dessous de l'inflation
fondamentale qui est à 5% au moment on
se parle là vous parlez 4 et demi 5 %
d'ici la fin de l'année monsieur Julien
en début d'année prochaine second moi je
crois que 4 et demi en fin d'année de
cette année mais pas seulement une
dernière heure aux auto on verra ça
dépend aussi de nos partenaires
commerciaux on voit du côté de l'Europe
ça ralentit significativement la Chine
les Etats-Unis et tout ça pourrait
affecter également l'économie canadienne
et possiblement que on va boire ce qu'il
a bonne nouvelle cette semaine s'il faut
en trouver une c'est qu'au moins les
attentes inflationnistes quand on
regarde les sondages que la Banque du
Canada a conduit auprès des entreprises
et des ménages on continue à croire que
dans trois quatre ans l'inflation sera
en deçà 3% et ça c'est la bonne nouvelle
évitez une accélération des attentes
inflationnistes mais en attendant
malheureusement on va casser des œufs
quand on fait une omelette donc il
faudra savoir faire mal et on voit
discours Ottawa préparez-vous ça va être
un peu dans les prochains mois là on n'a
pas prononcé officiellement le mot
récession par contre que ce soit juste
intrudo la ministre des Finances que
shuffle mais on a l'impression que c'est
le mot qui reste dans leur bouche si
vous voulez est-ce que le scénario de la
stagnation on est déjà dedans monsieur
Gignac
on sera pas comme dans les années 70
parce que les banques centrales ont tiré
le son ils comprennent très bien que
l'inflation c'est pire qu'une récession
on doit pas laisser soin cruster
d'autant plus que c'est les ménages les
plus démunis qui souffrent le plus
l'alimentation logement c'est important
dans leur budget eux et ils n'ont pas
des des augmentations de prix maison
souvent sont locataires donc à quelque
part on va vraiment on a choisi qu'on va
ramener l'inflation 2% et si ça signifie
qu'on y aura un passage obligé par une
récession on va l'observer
les gens une récession là ça sera pas
une dépression économique d'autant plus
qu'on a jamais vu ça madame c'est Arnaud
une situation comme ça ou pour l'instant
il y a deux postes vacants par chômeur
donc il y a quand même un bassin une
pénurie de main d'oeuvre qui fera en
sorte que devrait passer à travers ce
ralentissement économique ou récession
on va dire comme ça qui sera beaucoup
moins pire et pénible que ce qu'on a
vécu dans les cycles précédents est-ce
que c'est pour ça monsieur Gignac que
quand madame friedren parle cette
semaine elle dit et je me suis Trudeau
aussi c'est à dire le Canada va être là
pour soutenir les Canadiens mais ceux
qui sont les moins nantis ceux qui sont
les plus vulnérables on sent que on sera
prêt à aider mais vraiment de manière
beaucoup plus ciblée ce ne sera plus le
bar ouvert de la pandémie par des
expression
chirurgicale la pandémie c'est une chose
et en fait ce qu'il y avait à faire mais
là faut quand même éviter décidé de
commencer à remonter à avoir une
situation de budgétaire qui se
détériorerait de façon significative
donc on va cibler ça va être assez
chirurgicale selon moi c'est la
meilleure chose à faire versus envoyer
des 500 ou 20000 dollars à tout le monde
c'est pas la bonne situation la bonne
solution pourquoi parce que ça veut dire
que les taux de traits vont monter
encore davantage on va stimuler
l'économie donc pas de base de tps c'est
pas vrai tout le monde va recevoir un
chèque on va cibler on va s'occuper
plutôt des plus démunis et par la suite
le taux d'inflation va décélérer et
l'économie après un ralentissement
important où les gens récession pour
repartir sur des bons fondements solides
puisque c'est ça que ça prend un
inflation faible pour avoir des gains de
productivité des investissements et
enlever de l'incertitude économique
toujours très clair Clément Gignac merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce soir
au plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]